everyone knows what a Jedi is but who's
in charge of the Jedi Order and what
happens to trainees who don't pass their
tests if you're wondering about the
hierarchy of the galaxy's guardians of
justice and peace here's your guide the
lowest rank in the Jedi hierarchy are
Jedi younglings also known as initiating
to the book Jedi versus Sith the
essential guide to the force younglings
are children sensitive to the force who
were gathered from across the galaxy is
infants to be trained as future Jedi the
Jedi path a manual for students of the
forest explains that at one time young
adults and adolescents were recruited as
Jedi younglings but the order found that
these older recruits were already
exposed to negative emotions that could
push them to the dark side as a result
the Jedi began recruiting children who
were younger and more innocent
younglings don't train with mentors
one-on-one instead they're separated
into small groups called clans and
trained together within those clans once
younglings learn the basics they must
take a series of tests known as the
initiate which have included such tasks
as building a lightsaber though the
initiative changed over time their
ultimate goal is to determine students
knowledge of the Jedi Code and ability
to conquer the dark side
unlike the group training for younglings
Padawans receive one-on-one coaching and
real-life missions a significant hurdle
for most Padawans to clear similar to
younglings Padawans must also pass a
series of trials to move up in rank
these tests include the trial of skill
the trial of courage the trial of flesh
the trial of spirit in the trial of
insight the trials test a Padawans
mental and physical abilities and
determine if they are ready to become a
full-fledged Jedi the force is with you
young Skywalker
you on budget I yet not every Padawan
graduates to the rank of Jedi Knight but
unsuccessful initiates can still become
members of the Jedi service corps the
organization is separated into four arms
agricultural medical educational and
exploration the agricultural core uses
the Force to help ensure that the
Republic has enough food to go around
the Medical Corps is considered one of
the most advanced medical organizations
in the Republic with its members
performing specialized procedures and
triage work on battlefields across the
galaxy the educational Corps worked with
the Jedi archives translating and
updating records the most exciting
branch is arguably the exploration Corps
whose members are sent to the far-flung
corners of space to make new discoveries
Jedi Knights are full-fledged members of
the order expected to uphold peace in
the galaxy and the ideals of the Jedi
Code the most common way to become a
Jedi Knight is by passing trials as a
Padawan but an individual can also be
granted the title by performing a heroic
deed like obi-wan Kenobi assuming the
rank after defeating Darth Maul at this
point in the hierarchy Jedi Knights
still have much to learn about the force
but they no longer carry out their
duties under the direct supervision of a
Jedi Master
most Jedi Knights carry out their
missions alone testing their
self-discipline and upholding the
principles of the Jedi Code when people
think of the Jedi two things usually
come to mind the force and lightsabers
who are the Jedi in many cases those who
specialized in the manipulation of the
force pursue the title of Jedi Council
are most of these Jedi are focused on
using their connection to the force to
resolve conflicts in a peaceful way the
most esteemed Jedi consular masters
serve on the reconciliation council a
select group of Jedi who work directly
with the Republic diplomatic corps to
engage in diplomacy and interplanetary
relations there are many different ways
for jedi consulars to use their talents
within the order jedi seers use deep
meditation to connect to the force and
receive visions of the past present and
future
for instance the prophecy of the one who
will bring balance to the force was the
product of visions received by Jedi
seers who recorded their findings in the
Jedi archives other counselors become
Jedi healers who use their connection to
the forest to mend broken bodies other's
work as Jedi ambassadors and Jedi
diplomats serving as representative
and various government bodies in
activist movements respectively other
councillors might become Jedi lore
keepers dedicated to maintaining the
Jedi archives in the years leading up to
the Clone Wars the Republic had no
standing army instead specialized Jedi
Knights known as Guardians acted as the
first line of defense for the galaxy
guardians are divided into three main
subclasses peacekeepers temple security
and star fighters peacekeepers act as
galactic police trained in crowd control
and de-escalation of threats Jedi
assigned to temple security protect the
Jedi Temple on the planet Khorasan as
their name implies star fighters serve
as the pilots of the Jedi Order
particularly gifted Jedi guardians may
be known as battle masters tasked with
teaching lightsaber form and technique
or Cadence's to Jedi and training some
guardians come to specialize in fighting
with weapons other than a lightsaber
being awarded the title of exotic
weapons specialists these weapons can
include whips flails blasters and even
double bladed lightsaber x' jedi
sentinels are like the orders wildcards
sentinels pursue training and
disciplines that are also available to
non force-sensitive beams in doing so
they add modern insight and skills to
the Jedi orders ancient teachings common
pursuits for Jedi sentinels include
specializing in computer systems
manipulation of technology and hacking
into and disabling security mechanisms
other sentinels do exceedingly well on
missions that require stealth and
infiltration one particular group of
sentinels known as the Jedi shadows
serve as the orders assassins in excel
at sneaky less combat oriented tasks
Jedi sentinels are also distinguished by
often remaining in one area for much
longer than other jedi acting as
watchmen for particular regions of the
galaxy if a Jedi has shown exemplary
skill deep knowledge of the force and
successfully trained an apprentice to
become a Jedi Knight they may be granted
the title of Jedi Master
don't put the Jedi Master son a master's
purpose is to be a positive force in the
galaxy and to expand the influence of
the Jedi Order what separates a Jedi
Master from a Jedi Knight is that
they're exceptional achievements and
experience make them uniquely qualified
to teach the younger members of the
order in addition to teaching younger
Jedi they are also naturally fit to lead
the order not just by example but by
sitting on one of the four Jedi councils
that govern the order the four councils
are known as the Council of first
knowledge the council of reconciliation
the Council of reassignment and the High
Council the Council of first knowledge
oversees the education of younger Jedi
and the dissemination of materials from
the Jedi archives this council is
usually comprised of counselors who
became law keepers the council of
reconciliation meanwhile deals in
politics and diplomacy this council is
also regularly filled with counselors as
well as diplomats and ambassadors the
Council of reassignment governs the Jedi
service corps dictating which body each
initiate will be funneled into after
they fail to advance on the path to Jedi
knighthood these councils are all
governed by the High Council during the
Clone Wars the High Council was made up
of five lifetime appointees for long
term appointees and three short-term
appointees making for a total of twelve
council members the High Council
oversees everything within the order and
is crucial to its stability and success
the highest-ranking member within the
High Council is given the title master
of the order this prestigious position
is only obtained by those who have
demonstrated incredible knowledge of the
ways of the Jedi in the years leading up
to the Clone Wars the title of Master of
the order was held by lifetime appointee
mace windu after the Clone Wars began
Master Windu decided to take a more
active role in commanding troops on the
battlefield and insisted that the title
be passed to Master Yoda though master
of the order is a prestigious position
they are still outranked by one final
position the Grand Master the Grand
Master is the most prestigious rank in
the Jedi hierarchy awarded to only the
wisest and most skilled the Jedi High
Council must unanimously vote to bestow
the title on to them Grand Master's
often serve in conjunction with the
master of the order leading the Jedi
High Council while at one time several
Jedi Masters could be given the title at
once that practice ended long before the
time of the Clone Wars one of the most
critical roles held by the Grand Master
to pass on their knowledge to the next
generation of Jedi part of this Duty
involves training younglings in the ways
of the force two notable figures have
achieved the title of Grandmaster during
the Clone Wars Master Yoda was
recognized as the Grand Master of the
Jedi Order afterward at least in the old
expanded universe books Luke Skywalker
invokes the title of Grand Master as he
rebuilds the Jedi Order following the
fall of the Empire check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Star Wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]